cher monsieur le président du conseil
draguer chers collègues je me permettrai
de m'exprimer sur le terme qui ont été
inscrits à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
sur le plan économique et le
réchauffement climatique
pour beaucoup cela correspond évidemment
à tout ce dont nous nous occupons et à
la position de la russie si j'ai compris
d'après les
interventions précédentes tout cela
correspond
l'an dernier dont sur le fond de la
grave crise entraînée par la pandémie
les mesures économiques ont été prises
par les pays du g20 était justement de
combler le déficit
et essayer de lancer donc une
reconstruction de l'économie et toutes
ces mesures exceptionnelles
avec l'achat de valeurs par les
banques centrales
et en gros c'est ce qui vient d'être dit
actuellement et donc en russie avec les
vastes mesures de soutien notamment aux
pme et aussi au secteur de santé le
déficit a augmenté de 4% ce qui a permis
notamment
d'obtenir leur table un rétablissement
du marché de travail et nous avons
normaliser notre politique
macroéconomique de façon être positive
mais nous avons durci les mesures
créditeurs
dans le g20 la situation est un peu
différente si le déficit du budget était
de 3
8% en 2018 2019 et là aujourd'hui ça a
augmenté à 12 pour cent mille 2 % donc
là
c'est quand même un niveau élevé
actuellement 8 8 % et 40 % du bénéfice
de tous les pays du g20 pour l'année
revient essentiellement aux états unis
je le dis parce que nous comprenons tous
aujourd'hui la situation de cette cette
situation économique et c'est une
situation qui est mondiale et
donc on n'a pas tout à fait obtenu la
stabilité et il ya une augmentation des
tarifs sur les prix de consommation et
les prix des biens de consommation sur
l'énergie donc ces phénomènes
donc on a sept ce déficit dans les
grands pays industrialisés et donc cela
est lié à une grande influence inflation
pardon dans tous les pays
comme nous l'avons dit nous avons les
ignares des inégalités qui se renforce
ici on a sept phénomène de spirale est
une nécessité de normaliser la situation
macro
donc il est important ici de pouvoir
réguler l'équilibré entre l'offre et la
demande et en même temps résoudre les
problèmes de rupture et d'inégalités
sociales nous avons toujours saluer et
nous saluons les mesures
de soutien aux pays les plus pauvres et
sans cela ou ne pourra pas avoir de
développement durable à l'échelle
mondiale
d'ailleurs ces derniers temps
même les pays les plus développés
travaille là dessus notamment du
g20
donc ces éléments de politiques
budgétaires sont aujourd'hui la priorité
des pays du g20 et malgré
les efforts qui ont été faits notamment
pour l'accès au vaccin
est encore beaucoup de pays qui sont
privés de cet accès je considère qu'une
concurrence déloyale petit déloyale qui
est mise en place
malhonnête il ya le problème de
reconnaissance des vaccins il ya la
question
qu'est que qu'il faudrait que l om s
accélère la reconnaissance des vaccins
sur leur sécurité leur efficacité leur
fiabilité et plus cela plus vite cela
fait plus vite nous pourrons reprendre
une activité économique normale et
notamment pour le secteur touristique
je crois que les pays
les pays du g20 doivent travailler au
niveau de leur ministère de la santé
publique pour la reconnaissance des
vaccins
les experts sont bien d'accord sur le
fait que nous allons encore souffrir
longtemps du coronavirus des contenus du
fait que ce virus ne continue à évoluer
à muter et donc il faut que on est un
système de renouvellement des vaccins
qu'ils soient mises en place
donc j'avais dit que la russie avait
enregistré un vaccin le spoutnik v qui a
été acceptée aujourd'hui par de 70 pays
et qui touche aux gros 4 milliard de
personnes et qui a prouvé son efficacité
et sur la base 2c'est
composant la russie aussi développer un
vaccin et léger le vaccin
light qui est aussi proposé aux pays
européens nos partenaires
donc cette lutte contre le coronavirus
nécessite aussi une amélioration du
système d'accès aux soins de santé et
l'augmentation là le renforcement de la
coopération internationale sur ce plan
compte tenu de cette situation
avec l' oms le travail avec l'om mais
c'est de plus en plus important et cela
doit être soutenue au niveau
international il ne faut pas admettre
des actes qui limitent cette coopération
et j'en ai parlé récemment encore avec
le président français monsieur ma grande
encore une fois l'évolution des marchés
sur les ressources énergétiques ont
prouvé que ce secteur est aussi
vulnérable jouvet en parlait il ya la
question de l'accès aux sources
d'énergie et ce que je voudrais ajouter
à ce qui a été dit c'est que
de la stabilité sur ce marché dépend de
la stabilité d'une manière générale de
tous les participants de ce marché de
tous les acteurs il s'agit ici de mettre
en place une politique à long terme avec
des discussions approfondies pragmatique
sur
à partir de considérations purement
eicher collègues dans l'ensemble le gage
de la reprise de l'économie à long terme
l'augmentation du niveau de vie de la
population
ça veut dire que il faut mettre en place
des conditions d'un travail hors de
toute discrimination
et c'est là
le l'objectif du travail du g20 je vous
remercie pour votre attention